A fitness to practice investigation can feel like your whole world is falling apart, but it doesn't have to. In this episode, I'm joined by a legal expert to explore what psychologists need to know before the HCPC comes knocking. Whether you're under investigation, you're concerned about someone else's practice, or you just want to feel more prepared, this conversation is well worth staying tuned for. Hope you find it super useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a
面对执业能力调查可能会让你感觉整个世界都要崩塌了，但其实不必如此。在本期节目中，我邀请了一位法律专家，共同探讨心理学家在HCPC（英国健康与护理专业委员会）找上门之前需要了解的知识。无论你目前是否正在接受调查，是否担心他人的执业行为，或者只是想让自己更有准备，这期对话都非常值得一听。希望你会觉得它非常有用。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，
qualified clinical psychologist. Now in order to be able to say that to you, it means that in the UK I am registered and regulated with and by what's called the HCPC, which comes with a whole set of standards, protocols and guidance. But what happens if people do not stick to their professional codes of conduct? What happens if things get a bit wobbly? Well, we do have a regulatory body for a reason. And today we are taking a deep dive into that process. So with no further ado, let's cut to our chat and I will catch you on the other side.
一名合格的临床心理学家。能够这样向大家介绍自己，意味着在英国，我已在HCPC注册并受其监管，这伴随着一整套标准、规程和指导方针。但如果有人不遵守职业行为准则会怎样？如果情况变得有些棘手又会怎样？嗯，我们设立监管机构是有原因的。今天，我们将深入探讨这一流程。那么，废话不多说，让我们直接进入访谈，稍后再见。
I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Nicholas Sterling. Hi Nicholas. Hello, how are you going? I'm really well, thank you. I hope you are well too. So thank you for pitching this podcast episode to me. Could you firstly tell us, in case people are not aware,
我想欢迎今天的嘉宾尼古拉斯·斯特林。你好，尼古拉斯。你好，你怎么样？我很好，谢谢。希望你也一切都好。感谢你向我提议录制这期播客。首先，如果大家还不了解，你能告诉我们
what or who are the HCPC? Okay, so the Health and Care Professions Council is a regulatory body. So it's actually a statutory body, meaning it's created by a government statute, which is governs health care professionals. Now there's about 14 different professions that it governs. It used to govern social workers as well, which is a big one, but that now is governed by Social Work England. So essentially, if you're in contact with someone in relation to your health outside of nurses and doctors, the person
HCPC是什么，或者他们是谁吗？好的，健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）是一个监管机构。它实际上是一个法定机构，意味着它是根据政府法规设立的，旨在管理医疗保健专业人员。它目前管理着大约14种不同的职业。它过去也管理社会工作者，这是一个大类，但现在由“英格兰社会工作”机构管理。所以本质上，如果你在医疗保健方面与护士和医生以外的人员接触，那么这个人
you're in contact with is likely governed by the HCPC. So it's a regulator with government powers and the reason why that's useful to understand is that if the HCPC requests a document as a regulator, they do have the powers of government meaning that they can make sure that you give it to them. It's been around for quite a while now, it used to be called the HCP. It's a body that I think it's worth understanding just from the outset. It's a body that's essentially set up
很可能就是由HCPC管理的。它是一个拥有政府权力的监管机构，理解这一点之所以重要，是因为如果HCPC作为监管机构要求提供文件，他们拥有政府赋予的权力，这意味着他们可以确保你必须提供。它已经存在相当长一段时间了，过去被称为HPC。我认为从一开始就有必要了解这个机构。它本质上是
to protect the public. Now, as a psychologist or another healthcare professional, your dealings with the HCP can often be a little bit negative, meaning that they're asking for money, they're raising fees, which is a common complaint. But essentially, if we understand that the purpose of the HCPC is as a public protection body. So it's there essentially to make sure that those people that you work with,
为了保护公众而设立的。作为心理学家或其他医疗保健专业人员，你与HCPC的往来有时可能会有些负面，比如他们要求缴费、提高费用，这是常见的抱怨。但本质上，如果我们理解HCPC的宗旨是作为公众保护机构，那么它存在的目的就是确保你与之共事的人，
fellow psychologists or if you're working within the NHS, a radiologist or a podiatrist or a paramedic, that they are of particular standards. So what we really want as a society, I think, is people knowing how to do their jobs. So there'll be various standards that each person has to meet in order to be in order to be able to be registered by the HCPC. So I think overall it's a really positive idea how it's actually how they perform their duties can be difficult for people to understand sometimes. It can often be underfunded, meaning that people if a complaint is raised against someone it can take a long time to process. You may have different case managers. So you can become quite frustrated with them. But overall it's a body there to protect the public. I think that's the best way of analysing it. Amazing. And is it all funded by the people
无论是同行心理学家，还是你在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作时遇到的放射科医生、足病医生或护理人员，他们都符合特定的标准。我认为，作为社会，我们真正想要的是人们知道如何做好自己的工作。因此，每个人在获得HCPC注册之前都必须达到各种标准。所以我认为总体而言，这是一个非常积极的理念，尽管他们执行职责的方式有时可能让人难以理解。它经常面临资金不足的问题，这意味着如果有人提出投诉，处理过程可能需要很长时间。你可能会遇到不同的个案经理，因此可能会对他们感到相当沮丧。但总的来说，这是一个旨在保护公众的机构。我认为这是分析它的最好方式。太棒了。那么，它的资金全部来自
it's regulated? Or is there some funding from government, for example? That might be a question you don't know the answer, but I just, yeah, I wondered that. My understanding is it's primarily funded and almost exclusively funded by its members. I mean, I wouldn't absolutely quote me on that, but from my experience having worked with the HCPC, that's the understanding staff have. And as you guys are obviously well aware, psychologists who are listening, it costs a fair bit of money to be a member of the HCPC.
被监管者吗？还是有政府拨款？这可能是一个你不知道答案的问题，但我只是，是的，我很好奇。据我所知，它的资金主要且几乎全部来自其成员。我的意思是，我不会绝对保证这一点，但根据我与HCPC合作的经验，这是工作人员的共识。而且正如你们显然很清楚的那样，正在收听节目的心理学家们，成为HCPC的成员需要花费不少钱。
So that's in theory where your money is going. I mean, there are shareholders and the like, but essentially it's there for the good of its own professions. Yeah, so it's not there to make money. Okay, but that said, if anyone's listening to this and you are working in the UK and you're using one of the protected titles as a psychologist. That would be, for example, clinical psychologist, counselling psychologist, forensic psychologist, there's a few more as well. But those are protected titles, and if you have that qualification,
所以理论上这就是你们的钱去向的地方。我的意思是，虽然有股东之类的，但本质上它是为了其所属职业的利益而存在的。是的，所以它不是为了赚钱。好的，话虽如此，如果有人正在收听这期节目，并且你在英国工作，正在使用心理学家的受保护头衔。例如，临床心理学家、咨询心理学家、法医心理学家，还有其他一些头衔。但这些都是受保护的头衔，如果你拥有该资格，
you're using that title. You must be registered and regulated by the HCPC. This is not optional. And actually, if you see somebody using one of those titles and you don't think that they are appropriately qualified in this country to be using that, you can contact the HCPC to kind of make some inquiries about whether that person is acting with integrity, should we say. So yeah, I am registered with the HCPC, which means that I will get renewal documents once a year, so that's when they drop into my email inbox.
并且正在使用该头衔，你就必须在HCPC注册并受其监管。这不是可选的。实际上，如果你看到有人在使用这些头衔，而你认为他们在这个国家没有获得相应的执业资格，你可以联系HCPC，询问该人是否诚信执业。所以，是的，我在HCPC注册了，这意味着我每年会收到一次续期文件，它们会出现在我的电子邮件收件箱里。
I will get information about payments when they're due, when I've paid them. Sometimes people get told that they have got to do a CPD audit, continuing professional development, but one other time when people might hear from the HCPC might be if they have had a fitness to practice issue lodged against them, but as you are going to tell us later you can actually also do that yourself, you can nominate yourself for that. Could you tell us a little bit about what this fitness to practice process is like, please, Nick? Yeah, I mean, it's something that I think
我会收到关于缴费时间以及缴费完成的信息。有时人们会被告知必须进行CPD（持续专业发展）审计，但人们可能从HCPC听到的另一种情况是，如果他们被投诉存在执业能力问题，但正如你稍后会告诉我们的，你其实也可以主动申报。尼克，你能告诉我们这个执业能力流程是什么样的吗？好的，我的意思是，我认为
it's very relevant for all people regulated by the HCPC to have a general understanding of. And I'm always quite not surprised anymore, but it's always interesting to note that a lot of people even very experienced people have very little knowledge about the fitness practice process. So I sometimes run webinars and we have some very experienced heads of hospitals, psychologists particularly, and they will have what I would argue is a very limited understanding of because they haven't really encountered it that much yet and then they encounter it and it becomes quite clear to them
这对所有受HCPC监管的人来说，有一个大致的了解是非常相关的。我总是，不再感到惊讶了，但注意到很多人，即使是非常有经验的人，对执业能力流程也知之甚少，这总是很有趣。我有时会举办网络研讨会，参加的有非常有经验的医院院长，特别是心理学家，他们对该流程的理解在我看来非常有限，因为他们还没有真正遇到过，然后当他们遇到时，就会很清楚地意识到
that, wow, I probably should have known a little bit more. So the fitness to practice process is about protecting someone's fitness to practice, meaning protecting society's desire to have people who do their profession do it competently. So there were various standards of proficiency, the various standards that all registrants need to uphold. And if you don't uphold these standards, the idea is essentially
哇，我可能应该多了解一点。所以执业能力流程是为了保护某人的执业能力，意味着保护社会希望从事该职业的人能够胜任工作的愿望。因此，有各种专业标准，所有注册者都需要遵守。如果你不遵守这些标准，其理念本质上是
in a very broad, simplistic sense, is that you will be held to account. The fitness to practice regime is run by the HCPC, meaning that people can make complaints, various people members of the public make complaints. In terms of a percentage, it's worthwhile understanding who makes these complaints against a psychologist. So the overwhelming majority of complaints are raised by members of the public. So they can be clients, they can be someone who's read an article that you've written, as I say, as a psychologist. They've seen you on the television for more experienced ones. They've heard, seen your social media posts,
用一个非常宽泛、简单的方式来说，就是你将被追究责任。执业能力制度由HCPC运营，这意味着人们可以提出投诉，各种公众成员都可以提出投诉。就百分比而言，了解是谁对心理学家提出这些投诉是值得的。绝大多数投诉是由公众提出的。他们可以是客户，可以是读过你文章的人，正如我所说，作为心理学家。对于更有经验的人，他们可能在电视上见过你。他们听过、看过你的社交媒体帖子，
a member of the public that doesn't necessarily have to be directly related to you in the sense that was your patient, was your colleague. So the member of the public is the great majority. Other colleagues is another, I think about 20% of cases are raised by other colleagues or people who work with you, your boss, your workmate. And then there are also anonymous complaints.
一个公众成员，不一定非要与你有直接关系，比如是你的病人或同事。所以公众成员占了绝大多数。其他同事是另一类，我认为大约20%的案例是由其他同事或与你共事的人、你的老板、你的工友提出的。此外还有匿名投诉。
There was small amount that happened. So you can have anonymous complaints. The HCPC generally prefers not to receive anonymous complaints, but in certain circumstances that can happen. But I think we're talking about two or 3%. We can obviously wear the protection of a person who's involved in the complaint
发生的情况很少。所以你可以有匿名投诉。HCPC通常倾向于不接受匿名投诉，但在某些情况下可能会发生。但我认为我们谈论的是2%或3%。我们显然可以保护参与投诉的人，
is prima facie more important than identifying them. But essentially the purpose of the fitness to practice investigation, the HCPC needs to be able to tell the person who the complaint's raised against, who's raising the complaint. So therefore they can prepare properly on how to respond to that complaint.
这在表面上比识别他们更重要。但本质上，执业能力调查的目的是，HCPC需要能够告诉被投诉人是谁提出了投诉，这样他们才能为回应投诉做好充分准备。
The final way a complaint is raised is a self-referral. Now this is quite common and people are often quite surprised by that. So issues related to health, often people will self-refer. That may be health in the broad sense of physical health, that may be health in the sense that there's an addiction issue. So having an understanding that you're unable to practice competently and then raising that concern with the HCPC, so filling out a document and sending it to the HCPC or calling one of their numbers and explaining that actually I
最后一种提出投诉的方式是自我申报。这很常见，人们对此往往感到非常惊讶。所以与健康相关的问题，人们通常会自我申报。这可能是广义上的身体健康，也可能是成瘾问题。所以，意识到自己无法胜任工作，然后向HCPC提出这一担忧，即填写一份文件并发送给HCPC，或者拨打他们的电话号码，解释说实际上我
can't do this for reason A, I have cancer, reason B, I'm suffering from a substance abuse and being honest and transparent in that process is really helpful from the HCPC's perspective and that'll also reflect well upon you as you move forward. So once a complaint is raised against you, you then can have a three stage sort of process. So a complaint will be raised
因为A原因（我有癌症）或B原因（我患有药物滥用）而无法做到这一点，在这个过程中保持诚实和透明，从HCPC的角度来看是非常有帮助的，这在你未来前进时也会对你有良好的反映。所以一旦有人对你提出投诉，你就会经历一个三阶段的流程。投诉会被提出，
and we dealt with by triage, whereby there's people in an office at the HCPC will determine whether there's anything at all within this complaint. If there is, then it'll move to the investigation stage. Now the investigation stage is probably where most people have contact with it. So for example, if a complaint is raised against you,
并由分诊部门处理，HCPC办公室的人员会确定投诉中是否有任何实质内容。如果有，那么它将进入调查阶段。调查阶段可能是大多数人与之接触的阶段。例如，如果有人对你提出投诉，
you'll receive an email or a letter defining what the complaint is and the fact that there is an investigation underway. That investigation process can last anywhere between two months to three, four years, ideally the shortest spectrum, but it can take a longer process. Then the decision is made
你会收到一封电子邮件或信件，说明投诉内容以及调查正在进行的事实。该调查过程可能持续两个月到三、四年不等，理想情况下是较短的时间，但可能需要更长的过程。然后做出决定，
whether this will go to an ICP, it's an investigation committee panel, and they will determine whether that will then go to a final hearing. Now most cases are closed far before it reaches an ICP. If it does reach an ICP, an investigation committee panel, and they decide there is a case to answer, that will then go to a final hearing panel, which is a longer process and is similar to a court. So it's a tribunal essentially whereby a thorough examination of the evidence will go forward. And it's only generally for misconduct cases that it will reach that high level. And if it goes to that high level, then the various sanctions available are a strike off, a warning, these sort of ideas or these sort of sanctions.
决定是否将其提交给ICP（调查委员会小组），他们将决定是否进入最终听证会。大多数案件在到达ICP之前就已结案。如果确实到达了ICP，且他们决定有案可查，那么它将进入最终听证小组，这是一个更长的过程，类似于法庭。所以它本质上是一个法庭，将对证据进行彻底审查。通常只有不当行为案件才会达到那个高水平。如果达到那个水平，那么可用的各种制裁包括除名、警告，这些类型的制裁。
So it's worth understanding that less than 1% of cases will go to a final hearing. And as a registered psychologist in the UK, the 30,000 members, 0.06 of psychologists will have a sanction against them through the HCPC. So this is a very small number. However, there are also, it's worth understanding that in any given year between 200 and 250 cases are raised against psychologists, which is first or
所以值得了解的是，不到1%的案件会进入最终听证会。作为英国的注册心理学家，在3万名成员中，0.06%的心理学家会受到HCPC的制裁。所以这是一个非常小的数字。然而，值得了解的是，在任何一年中，针对心理学家的投诉有200到250起，这是HCPC管理的14个职业中排名第一或
second in terms of the 14 professions, the HCPC govern. So it is the second most complained against profession. And that for me is a very interesting point, because it sort of reflects on the nature of the profession itself. Why do psychologists have more complaints raised against them? And that's something we might be able to discuss later. But essentially, it's worth understanding that if you're a psychologist, your chance of being struck off are very, very, very small if you're doing the right thing, and just as a percentage. However, there are 235 to 250 cases raised annually against psychologists. So your chance of having some involvement with the FTP process is not negligible. Whether you're actually involved
第二多的。所以它是被投诉第二多的职业。对我来说，这是一个非常有趣的观点，因为它反映了职业本身的性质。为什么心理学家受到的投诉更多？这是我们稍后可以讨论的问题。但本质上，值得了解的是，如果你是一名心理学家，如果你做正确的事，你被除名的几率非常、非常、非常小，这只是一个百分比。然而，每年针对心理学家有235到250起投诉。所以你参与FTP（执业能力）流程的几率并非微不足道。无论你是否参与
as a complainant against a colleague, whether you have a complaint raised against you, whether you're involved in the process as writing a professional report or appearing as a witness. So it's worth understanding how it operates. Yeah, it is. And it sounds like a very multi-layered process. But I guess what you're saying is the first thing you may know about this, if this is not a self-disclosure, is you're going about your normal day,
作为针对同事的投诉人，无论你是否被投诉，无论你是否作为撰写专业报告或出庭作证的人参与其中。所以了解它是如何运作的是值得的。是的，确实如此。这听起来是一个非常多层次的过程。但我猜你想说的是，如果这不是自我披露，你可能知道的第一件事就是，你正在过着正常的日子，
you open your emails, and then suddenly it feels like the world perhaps implodes a little bit. Because somebody, which might be an anonymous complainant, or it might be someone that's named in that email has raised a fitness to practice concern. Now of course that's gonna feel probably incredibly derailing especially if you didn't see it coming at all. This is gonna have a big emotional impact isn't it, Nicholas? I mean, it's worth noting that outside of imprisonment, your profession really defines who you are.
你打开电子邮件，突然感觉世界似乎有点崩塌了。因为有人，可能是匿名投诉人，也可能是邮件中提到的人，提出了执业能力担忧。当然，这可能会让人感觉极其受挫，特别是如果你完全没有预料到的话。这会产生巨大的情感影响，不是吗，尼古拉斯？我的意思是，值得注意的是，除了监禁之外，你的职业真正定义了你是谁。
So if you think of sanctions in a criminal sense, and I've worked in criminal law and regulatory law, outside of restricting your freedom, restricting your ability to practice your profession is probably the second most powerful thing an organization can do. So that can be the most destabilizing process. And particularly in my experience,
所以如果你从刑事意义上考虑制裁，我从事过刑法和监管法工作，除了限制你的自由之外，限制你从事职业的能力可能是组织能做的第二件最有影响力的事情。所以这可能是最令人不安的过程。特别是在我的经验中，
having worked for quite a few years, primarily with psychologists. Psychologists are often well equipped to deal with these sort of issues through their training. I mean, in theory, you guys should have some sort of knowledge about how we deal with these sort of issues through their training. I mean, in theory, you guys should be, have some sort of knowledge about how we deal with the various processes and various skills, techniques we can use to process anxiety or feeling unable to control a situation.
工作了相当多年，主要与心理学家打交道。心理学家通常通过培训有能力处理这些类型的问题。我的意思是，理论上，你们应该通过培训对我们如何处理这些类型的问题有一些了解。我的意思是，理论上，你们应该，对我们如何处理各种流程以及我们可以用来处理焦虑或感觉无法控制局势的各种技能、技巧有一些了解。
So I think what happens when an FTP process, a concern is raised against someone, all your sense of self can be completely rocked. And particularly with the length of the process, the nature of the concerns, these things can go for a long time and all you're gonna get is a letter in the mail saying this is a concern raised against you
所以我认为当FTP流程、担忧被提出时，你所有的自我感可能会完全动摇。特别是考虑到流程的长度、担忧的性质，这些事情可能会持续很长时间，而你得到的只是邮件里的一封信，说这是针对你提出的担忧，
and we'll be in touch. And you know what that can entail. You know, eventually in theory, that can lead to being struck off. Now that as I've explained is a very small percentage, but that doesn't mean it's not in your head. So I try and help those I work with. And I work a lot with the ACP UK,
我们会保持联系。你知道这可能意味着什么。你知道，最终在理论上，这可能导致被除名。正如我所解释的，这是一个非常小的百分比，但这并不意味着它不在你的脑海里。所以我试图帮助我共事的人。我与ACP UK（英国临床心理学家协会）合作很多，
so the Association of Clinical Psychologists UK. And we try to navigate ways of assisting members. And obviously there's gonna be various bodies that work with the various different types of psychologists. So I suggest that if you are a clinical psychologist, having some contact with these bodies, or if you're an educational psychologist, or various different types of psychologists. So I suggest that if you are a clinical psychologist, having some contact with these bodies, or if you're an educational psychologist, or the various different types can be really useful
所以是英国临床心理学家协会。我们试图寻找协助成员的方法。显然，会有各种机构与不同类型的心理学家合作。所以我建议，如果你是一名临床心理学家，与这些机构保持联系，或者如果你是一名教育心理学家，或者各种不同类型的心理学家。所以我建议，如果你是一名临床心理学家，与这些机构保持联系，或者如果你是一名教育心理学家，或者各种不同类型，这真的很有用，
in dealing with the process because you can't control it. And it's a feeling that I don't have control of this situation. You're waiting for an email to come back. So what I should suggest to people to do is to try and be proactive and understand that this fitness to practice process is there in theory to protect the public. And while this may feel like it's attacking you, to understand that you are part of a bigger process and to try and disassociate any sort of personal
在处理这个过程中，因为你无法控制它。这是一种我无法控制这种情况的感觉。你在等待电子邮件回复。所以我应该建议人们做的是，尝试主动出击，理解这个执业能力流程理论上是为了保护公众。虽然这可能感觉像是在攻击你，但要理解你是更大流程的一部分，并尝试剥离任何个人的
feelings of anger you may have, particularly if you know you've done nothing wrong. And let's be fair, most cases, nothing is proven cases, nothing is proven, and there's been no fault and there's been no misconduct. But the HCPC is there to rigorously check the process. So if you can try and logically think about how do I deal with this? And how do I accept the fact that it's a bit out of my control? That that's really the objective, but it is incredibly destabilizing. There's no two ways about it. Yeah, it really is. And, you know, thinking about the things that you're going to do in order of that which you're going to
愤怒情绪，特别是如果你知道自己没有做错任何事。老实说，大多数案件，什么都没有证明，没有过错，也没有不当行为。但HCPC在那里是为了严格检查流程。所以如果你能尝试逻辑地思考，我该如何处理这件事？我该如何接受它有点超出我控制的事实？这才是真正的目标，但它确实极其令人不安。这是毫无疑问的。是的，确实如此。而且，你知道，考虑到你将要做的那些事情的顺序，
do them, probably you're going to speak to someone who hopefully loves you. You know, you're going to speak to hopefully your supervisor. That's really important. So long as it's not your supervisor who's lodged a complaint. You're probably going to speak to your indemnity insurer as well. Would that be a good thing to do, Nicholas? Absolutely. I mean, in that order, absolutely. So supervision and the supervision is really, as I'm sure everyone's aware, is integral to the whole profession. And having a supervisor you have a great working relationship
你可能会先和爱你的人谈谈。你知道，你希望和你的主管谈谈。这真的很重要。只要不是你的主管提出了投诉。你可能也会和你的赔偿保险公司谈谈。那会是一件好事吗，尼古拉斯？绝对的。我的意思是，按那个顺序，绝对的。所以督导，正如我相信每个人都知道的那样，是整个职业不可或缺的一部分。拥有一个你与之有良好工作关系的督导
with is really important. And particularly if something like this arises. So the first things first is your supervisor. If you have a body that you're involved in, similar to the ACP UK, it is worthwhile potentially contacting them. A lot of these bodies have fitness to practice advice centers.
真的很重要。特别是如果发生了这样的事情。所以首先要做的是找你的主管。如果你参与了某个机构，类似于ACP UK，联系他们可能是有价值的。许多这些机构都有执业能力咨询中心。
So there'll be someone there to talk to about the case. And this can be done in a very general sense. People have this fear, well, if I'm discussing it with a professional body, is that going to reflect poorly upon me? But I'd argue, from my experience, having worked with a big professional body, quite the opposite, because a lot of these complaints, a lot of the complaints that are raised against professionals and the issues that they have in terms of dealing with the complaints are common. So if you're feeling really vulnerable and frustrated and angry, talking to someone from a representative body can be really useful. And obviously your insurer and that in that sense, whether you're going to get the psychological help you need, I'm not I'm not sure
所以会有人在那里谈论这个案例。这可以在一个非常普遍的意义上完成。人们有这种恐惧，好吧，如果我和专业机构讨论它，那会对我产生不好的影响吗？但我认为，根据我的经验，与一个大型专业机构合作，恰恰相反，因为许多这些投诉，许多针对专业人士提出的投诉以及他们在处理投诉方面遇到的问题都是常见的。所以如果你感到非常脆弱、沮丧和愤怒，与代表机构的人交谈真的很有用。显然还有你的保险公司，在这个意义上，你是否会得到你需要的心理帮助，我不确定
they're necessarily going to be able to provide that but they may give you some some guidelines, legal advice as well. So if it is a very serious matter straight off the bat, it probably worthwhile talking to your representative body and whether they think straight away you need to seek legal advice. But try to remain calm off from the outset remain calm and realize that this if you're in a 20 year career, 30 year career as a psychologist, it's not impossible this is going to come against you. There's going to be some sort
他们是否一定能提供，但他们可能会给你一些指导方针、法律建议。所以如果这是一个非常严重的问题，从一开始，可能值得和你的代表机构谈谈，看看他们是否认为你需要立即寻求法律建议。但尽量从一开始就保持冷静，保持冷静，并意识到，如果你在心理学家的职业生涯中有20年、30年，这并非不可能发生在你身上。会有某种
of issue raised against you and just accept this part of the process and breathe. That would be my straight off the advice. Can you still continue to practice when there is an FTP hanging over you or is that very much dependent on what the allegation is? Yes, you can in a simple sense. You can still work. At this stage, there are no, nothing is proven. You can still work unless there's been interim order application. So in very serious cases, usually within a week or two of the HCPC receiving that complaint,
针对你提出的问题，只需接受这是流程的一部分，然后呼吸。那将是我最直接的建议。当FTP悬在头上时，你还能继续执业吗？还是这很大程度上取决于指控是什么？是的，简单来说你可以。你仍然可以工作。在这个阶段，没有，什么都没有证明。你仍然可以工作，除非有临时命令申请。所以，在非常严重的案件中，通常在HCPC收到投诉后的一两周内，
they can schedule an interim order application. So what an interim order application is, is a very small hearing whereby the HCPC panel, which consists of three people, a chair, a layman, and a member of the profession, so a psychologist, they'll make a decision whether, and a member of the profession, so a psychologist. They'll make a decision whether it's safe for that person to continue practicing.
他们可以安排临时命令申请。所以什么是临时命令申请，这是一个非常小的听证会，HCPC小组由三个人组成，一名主席、一名外行和一名职业成员，即心理学家，他们将做出决定，是否，
Now, this is not a common occurrence. It only happens in severe cases. So if there are issues of sexual assault, criminal matters, boundary issues, but of the severe kind, those sort of types of case can have intramodular applications. But outside of those, and you'll know very quickly if there's gonna be intramodal application and a hearing,
以及职业成员，即心理学家。他们将做出决定，该人继续执业是否安全。现在，这不是常见的情况。它只发生在严重案件中。所以如果存在性侵犯、刑事问题、边界问题，但属于严重类型，这些类型的案件可能会有临时命令申请。但除此之外，而且如果会有临时命令申请和听证会，你会很快知道，
outside of those, you are free to continue practicing. Now, whether you tell your boss is a matter entirely up to you, there's no legal requirement, it's advisable as a legal professional, it's advisable, just because generally you guys are on the same team, unless they raise a complaint against you, and then they'll be well aware that it's advisable just because generally you guys are on the same team, unless they raise the complaint against you and then they'll be well aware that it's them that's raised it,
除此之外，你可以自由继续执业。至于你是否告诉你的老板，完全取决于你，没有法律要求，作为法律专业人士，这是可取的，只是因为通常你们在同一个团队，除非他们对你提出投诉，然后他们会很清楚，这是可取的，只是因为通常你们在同一个团队，除非他们提出了投诉，然后他们会很清楚是他们提出的，
but generally you are free to practice and what you say to your boss or to your colleagues is entirely up to you. Yeah, I guess I'm probably thinking about my own perspective too much really because I no longer work for an employer, I'm self-employed. I don't know that in all of my time in the NHS that anyone ever said they were under an FTP or had been. Is it more common in employment? Is it more common in private practice? Or is it a real melee? In terms of what types of people have concerns raised against them, it's across the board. I mean, I work at the moment with people involved in working within the NHS.
但通常你可以自由执业，你对老板或同事说什么完全取决于你。是的，我想我可能过多地从我自己的角度考虑了，因为我不再为雇主工作，我是自雇人士。我不知道在我NHS的所有时间里，是否有人说过他们正在接受FTP或曾经接受过。这在就业中更常见吗？在私人执业中更常见吗？还是一个真正的大杂烩？就什么类型的人会被提出担忧而言，这是普遍的。我的意思是，我目前与在NHS工作的人合作。
I have clients who have private practice. I don't think there's any way of defining it. I mean, potentially if you're involved, for example, in the NHS, you can have one complainant can make multiple complaints against various people. And that can happen, particularly in psychology. So that's worth understanding. So in that sense, there may be more complaints made by those working within broader organizations, but generally it's across the board.
我有私人执业的客户。我不认为有任何定义它的方法。我的意思是，如果你参与了，例如，在NHS中，你可以有一个投诉人对不同的人提出多项投诉。这可能会发生，特别是在心理学领域。所以这值得了解。所以在这个意义上，在更广泛组织内工作的人可能会有更多的投诉，但通常它是普遍的。
It's something that people and professionals as psychologists can deal with. And I'd argue, and this is something that I mentioned before, I'd argue that the nature of the profession dictates that vulnerable people can be involved. So as a psychologist, you're going to be working with people who who need sometimes serious help. Sometimes it's for marital issues. Obviously there's a broad spectrum of psychology. But there are also some people who are unwell.
这是人们和专业人士作为心理学家可以处理的事情。而且我认为，这是我之前提到的，我认为职业的性质决定了脆弱的人可能会参与其中。所以作为心理学家，你将与那些需要有时严重帮助的人一起工作。有时是为了婚姻问题。显然心理学有广泛的范围。但也有一些人身体不适。
There's no other way to say it in the sense that there's a psychiatric disorder. And these types of people, patients, clients, service users, they can be referred to all three. service users, they can be referred to all three, they can have a tendency to respond negatively to certain circumstances. I mean, I think that's pretty clear for you guys as psychologists to understand. So in my experience, particularly during my work with the HCPC, with whom I worked for two and a half,
没有其他说法，即存在精神疾病。而这些类型的人，病人、客户、服务使用者，他们可以被转介给所有三方。服务使用者，他们可以被转介给所有三方，他们可能倾向于对某些情况做出负面反应。我的意思是，我认为这对你们作为心理学家来说是很清楚的。所以根据我的经验，特别是在我与HCPC合作期间，我工作了两年半，
three years before I started to work on my own, in my experience, the HCPC receive a lot of complaints from vulnerable complainants. Yeah I guess you might get someone who's paranoid maybe who's then putting in complaints which to them feel very justified but to obviously people who are not paranoid or kind of experiencing any psychosis symptoms that really feels like that's not that's not at all what's happening or what has happened so I guess depending on what the complaint is it might affect how you feel about that
三年，在我开始自己工作之前，根据我的经验，HCPC收到了很多来自脆弱投诉人的投诉。是的，我想你可能会遇到偏执的人，他们提出的投诉对他们来说感觉非常合理，但对于显然没有偏执或没有经历任何精神病症状的人来说，这感觉根本不是正在发生的事情，也不是已经发生的事情，所以我猜取决于投诉是什么，它可能会影响你对它的感觉。
absolutely I mean I mean I wouldn't even paranoia and some form of schizophrenic or psychotic episode that can be people within suffering from that particular condition may make complaints, but even way down to a far less serious complaint, meaning someone has attachment issues and a psychologist ends a professional relationship due to the ceasing of their practice or they're moving or for various reasons
绝对的。我的意思是，我的意思是，我甚至不会说偏执和某种形式的精神分裂或精神病发作，患有该特定疾病的人可能会提出投诉，但即使是远没有那么严重的投诉，意味着某人有依恋问题，而心理学家由于其实践停止或他们搬迁或由于各种原因结束了专业关系，
why people change, move location and they've signed posted this perfectly along the whole way. So I'm gonna be leaving in six months, nine months, exactly as you guys know how to do and when practicing professionally. And even then the nature of the relationship with the client and I've had this actually quite a few times,
为什么人们改变、搬迁位置，而他们在此过程中一直完美地指引了这一点。所以我将在六个月、九个月后离开，正如你们在专业执业时所知道的那样。即使那样，与客户的关系性质，我实际上已经遇到过好几次了，
the complaint has been made by a vulnerable patient of a psychologist who is absolutely distraught that this psychologist leaving them. And this leads to a lot of anger, a lot of revisionism. So suddenly a lot of the practice, a lot of the work that they did together is viewed through a different prism and they now accuse them of inappropriate touching.
投诉是由心理学家的脆弱病人提出的，他们对心理学家离开他们感到非常痛苦。这导致了大量的愤怒、大量的修正主义。所以突然间，他们一起做的很多实践、很多工作被通过不同的棱镜看待，他们现在指责他们不适当的触摸。
I mean, that's a more extreme case, but they can definitely say that you left me abandoned and they now accuse them of inappropriate touching. I mean, that's a more extreme case, but they can definitely say that you left me abandoned and they're angry. And then they can write, and I've seen this with my work with the HCPC and actually with a recent client, they can write very, very structured letters to the HCPC as part of the complaint process, explaining in great detail what this person did wrong.
我的意思是，这是一个更极端的案例，但他们绝对可以说你抛弃了我，他们现在指责他们不适当的触摸。我的意思是，这是一个更极端的案例，但他们绝对可以说你抛弃了我，他们很生气。然后他们可以写，我在与HCPC的工作中看到过这种情况，实际上还有一位最近的客户，他们可以写非常、非常有条理的信件给HCPC，作为投诉过程的一部分，详细解释这个人做错了什么。
And if you're the HCPC, you're receiving this, it's well structured. This person may not necessarily have a psychiatric disorder, but may, but clearly is motivated because they had this personal relationship with this client, with this psychologist, sorry. And they can write pages of very organized reasons why this, this, this, their psychologist has done something wrong. The HCPC is just reading prima FACI what's in front of them. And they will essentially have to look at these complaints and take them on face value. And then you may know as a psychologist, you've done absolutely nothing wrong. The the psycho the ACPC are doing their job.
如果你是HCPC，你收到这个，它结构很好。这个人不一定有精神疾病，但可能有，但显然是因为他们与这个客户，抱歉，与这个心理学家有这种个人关系而受到激励。他们可以写几页非常有组织的理由，说明为什么这个，这个，这个，他们的心理学家做错了什么。HCPC只是在表面上阅读面前的内容。他们本质上必须查看这些投诉并按面值接受。然后你作为心理学家可能知道，你绝对没有做错任何事。HCPC正在做他们的工作。
They're saying everyone deserves to have their right. You know, maybe everyone deserves to have their complaint heard. So that looks quite clearly like a case that's going to pass the triage stage. That's going to go to an investigation, even though there's substantially nothing in it. And the psychologists, particularly if they have experience, will know that what they've done is correct.
他们说每个人都应该有他们的权利。你知道，也许每个人都应该有他们的投诉被听到。所以这看起来很清楚是一个将通过分诊阶段的案例。它将进入调查，即使其中基本上没有什么内容。而心理学家，特别是如果他们有经验，会知道他们所做的是正确的。
And they've done it. Their note taking's fine. Everything's fine. They know this patient. But you can't just respond to the HCPC saying, this patient has these major mental health issues, or this patient, but you can't just respond to the HCPC saying, this patient has these major mental health issues or this patient has this attachment issue to do with their childhood.
他们做到了。他们的笔记记录很好。一切都很好。他们了解这个病人。但你不能只是回应HCPC说，这个病人有这些主要的心理健康问题，或者这个病人，但你不能只是回应HCPC说，这个病人有这些主要的心理健康问题或者这个病人有这种与童年有关的依恋问题。
It doesn't work like that. So then the investigation process starts. So as I've explained to psychologists quite often, the fact that psychologists are the second most investigated profession of all HCPC regulated professions. It's to me interesting. So paramedics and psychologists are the two professions which have most complaints raised against them. Now that doesn't mean all psychologists are
它不是那样工作的。所以调查过程就开始了。正如我经常向心理学家解释的那样，心理学家是所有HCPC监管职业中被调查第二多的职业这一事实。对我来说很有趣。所以护理人员和心理学家是投诉最多的两个职业。现在这并不意味着所有心理学家都
struck off than anyone else. It just means that the nature of profession, I would argue, vulnerable people make these complaints and they can make multiple complaints against multiple people. And so it's worth knowing, understanding that these sort of people of these patients, these people involved in your work can also, if the relationship breaks down, can react negatively. So be aware of that is what I'd argue. Thank you. That's really helped me to kind of get an understanding with that example of how that might crop up for vulnerable patients. In order for us to kind of get an understanding of other examples where this might crop up for other referrals, have you got any other examples you could share Nick? I think what might be
比其他人更容易被除名。这只是意味着职业的性质，我认为，脆弱的人提出这些投诉，他们可以对多个人提出多项投诉。所以值得知道，理解这些类型的人，这些病人，这些参与你工作的人，如果关系破裂，也会做出负面反应。所以要意识到这一点，这是我会争论的。谢谢。这真的帮助我通过那个例子了解了脆弱病人可能会如何出现这种情况。为了让我们了解其他转介可能会出现这种情况的其他例子，你还有其他可以分享的例子吗，尼克？我想可能
most relevant is to give you some examples of cases that may affect a broader group of people. So everyone knows there's black and white cases. So there's clearly professional boundaries issues, having a sexual relationship with a client, these sort of things that are clearly gonna get you struck off. There's no question about that. That's the sort of thing that you see on every single drama as well.
最相关的是给你一些可能影响更广泛人群的案例。所以每个人都知道有黑白分明的案例。所以有明显的专业边界问题，与客户发生性关系，这些类型的事情显然会让你被除名。这是毫无疑问的。这是你在每一部电视剧中都能看到的事情。
But actually, as a psychologist watching those dramas, it makes us scream at the telly, because you're like, ah, this never happens. You know, it's always a psychologist who's the murderer or who's unethical. And in the most case, that is not my experience of the profession. So let me just leave that there. But on occasion it does happen and it's a serious concern. Absolutely. I mean, it does happen.
但实际上，作为一名观看这些电视剧的心理学家，这让我们对着电视尖叫，因为你会说，啊，这永远不会发生。你知道，总是心理学家是凶手或不道德的。而在大多数情况下，那不是我对这个职业的经验。所以让我把它留在那里。但偶尔它确实会发生，这是一个严重的问题。绝对的。我的意思是，它确实会发生。
I mean, when I was working with the HCPC, I would be prosecuting these cases, but they're rare. They're very rare. They're not the ones that clog up the system. They're definitely not the complex. They're not complicated because it's black and white, really, unless there's a denial of that relationship or whatever it may be.
我的意思是，当我与HCPC工作时，我会起诉这些案件，但它们很少见。它们非常罕见。它们不是堵塞系统的那种。它们绝对不是复杂的。它们不复杂，因为它是黑白分明的，真的，除非对那种关系有否认或无论它可能是什么。
But for me, the issues that people may face in a daily basis relate to two, sort of two areas. One I'd say is scope of practice. So whether you are actually fully qualified to undertake the particular role that you've undertaken, that is something that crops up, I wouldn't say very regularly, but it's something that I've seen quite often.
但对我来说，人们可能在日常基础上遇到的问题涉及两个，某种两个领域。一个我会说是执业范围。所以你是否真的完全有资格承担你所承担的特定角色，这是出现的事情，我不会说非常定期，但我经常看到。
So what that means, and I'll give you an example to illustrate the point. I had a client recently who acted on a parole board in a juvenile setting. So he's a juvenile in a juvenile prison. And this particular client was sitting on the body that's decided whether this person was likely to re-offend. Now they wrote a report, the report they thought was fine,
所以这意味着什么，我将举一个例子来说明这一点。我最近有一位客户在少年环境中担任假释委员会成员。所以他是一个少年，在少年监狱里。而这个特定的客户坐在决定这个人是否可能再犯的机构里。现在他们写了一份报告，他们认为报告很好，
there was no complaints about it. That inmate, juvenile was released and then committed a crime. Now you work backwards from these steps and that report became under analysis. So essentially the report that was written by a psychologist who said purported to be an expert in this area was now scrutinized.
没有关于它的投诉。那个囚犯，少年被释放，然后犯了罪。现在你从这些步骤倒推，那份报告受到了分析。所以本质上，那份由一名声称是该领域专家的心理学家撰写的报告现在受到了审查。
And under scrutiny, it came quite clear that they didn't have the appropriate training. Now, certain things, certain areas of psychology are quite niche, as you guys all know, but it is quite a broad spectrum of professions. So you can have an area of expertise in one area that overlaps
在审查之下，很明显他们没有接受过适当的培训。正如你们所知，心理学的某些领域非常细分，但它涵盖的职业范围非常广泛。因此，你可能在一个领域拥有专业知识，而该领域与其他领域存在重叠。
where one starts one stops is quite blurred. That's the nature of the profession. Someone can have a great deal of experience in one area which becomes highly relevant to a second one. Now I would argue having read the report and analyzed the report this person wrote it was excellent. There was no question it was an excellent report. But working backwards, it became clear at this particular field, you needed to have a particular qualification, this particular area of training, seven day course, 10 day course, you need to have written, I can't remember the exact details, it was a while ago. Like you need to be trained in expert witness work. Is that kind of an example?
从哪里开始、到哪里结束，界限相当模糊。这就是该行业的本质。一个人可能在一个领域拥有丰富的经验，而这些经验与第二个领域高度相关。现在，在阅读并分析了此人撰写的报告后，我认为这份报告非常出色。毫无疑问，这是一份出色的报告。但回过头来看，很明显在这个特定领域，你需要具备特定的资格，接受过特定的培训，比如七天课程、十天课程，你需要写过什么——我不记得确切细节了，那是很久以前的事了。就像你需要接受过专家证人工作的培训一样。这是一个例子吗？
It's part of it. Yeah, so you needed to be, you needed to have a specific document to be able to work within the sphere of juvenile detention centres. It's even that niche. So this specific area. This isn't about representing someone in court. This is about actually you need that qualification, that experience to be able to do that piece of work and you haven't got it, so you shouldn't be doing it. Absolutely. And so this could have been solved quite easy. And
这是其中的一部分。是的，你需要具备特定的文件才能在少年拘留中心领域工作。甚至细分到这种程度。所以这是特定的领域。这与在法庭上代表某人无关。这是关于你实际上需要那种资格、那种经验才能完成那项工作，而你没有，所以你不应该做。绝对是这样。这本来可以很容易解决。而且
this person was very professional and very good and that my client was highly competent. There was no issues with that. But because they didn't have this one thing that they were required, that became an HCPC case. It went quite far. So what I explained to people when I'm giving webinars, I say this quite often, is if you're unsure, talk to your supervisor, look it up, look to see if I'm going to act on behalf of someone or if I'm going to purport to be a particular expert,
这个人非常专业，非常优秀，我的客户能力也很强。这方面没有问题。但因为他们缺少了这一项必要的东西，这就变成了一个HCPC案件。事情闹得相当大。所以我给人们做网络研讨会时经常解释说，如果你不确定，就去问你的主管，去查一下，看看我是否要代表某人，或者我是否要声称自己是某位专家，
particularly say in educational psychology or forensic psychology. And if you do have a good understanding of this, just make sure that your documentation is in line with what you're purporting to do. Now, it seems simple, in most of the circumstances, there's not really that set requirement,
特别是在教育心理学或法医心理学方面。如果你对此有很好的理解，只需确保你的文件与你所声称要做的事情一致即可。现在，这看起来很简单，在大多数情况下，并没有那种硬性要求，
but in certain areas, be aware that you're not acting outside of your scope of practice. So that's one area that I think's worth just being aware of. It's not something you'd like you to encounter every day. And most people know what they know and they stick within their areas.
但在某些领域，要注意不要超出你的执业范围。所以我认为这是一个值得注意的领域。这不是你每天都会遇到的事情。大多数人都知道自己懂什么，并坚持在自己的领域内工作。
But if you just like, hey, wait a second, I'm not sure I'm quite the right person to do this. And I know in a world where income is really important, just be careful that you don't take that role unless you're fully qualified to take that role. So that'd be sort of the first area that I'd mentioned. Another one would be in terms of reporting. If you feel, for example, like someone you work with is doing something inappropriate, someone within your, another professional that you have contact with is doing something that they shouldn't be doing. It's a good idea to seek advice
但如果你觉得，嘿，等一下，我不确定自己是否是做这件事的合适人选。我知道在一个收入非常重要的世界里，除非你完全有资格担任该角色，否则要小心不要接受它。所以这大概是我提到的第一个领域。另一个领域是关于报告。如果你觉得，例如，你一起工作的人正在做不恰当的事情，或者你接触的另一位专业人士正在做他们不应该做的事情。寻求建议是一个好主意
from your supervisor immediately. And then if you both agree that this should be reported, report it as soon as possible. Now, the example I give is a case I had a while back where a woman who runs a clinic and has psychologists working within her clinic, but it's sort of a sub let's agreement, but it's under her name.
立即咨询你的主管。如果你们都同意应该报告，那就尽快报告。我举的例子是我前段时间处理过的一个案例，一位女性经营着一家诊所，诊所里有心理学家在工作，这是一种转租协议，但以她的名义。
So they're all experts in this particular area of psychology. Her name's on the door, but she has other people working with her, very common experience in the industry. This particular woman working for her formed a relationship with a client. It did happen. Inappropriate relationship. And the only reason she was notified, she found out about this,
所以他们都是该心理学特定领域的专家。门上挂着她的名字，但她有其他人与她一起工作，这在行业中是很常见的经历。这名在她手下工作的特定女性与一名客户建立了关系。确实发生了。不恰当的关系。她被通知、她发现这件事的唯一原因，
was the husband of the client notified her saying someone who works under your roof is forming a relationship with my wife. Now, what my client did was became aware of this quite quickly. She knew that something was, she had her suspicions for quite a while and then didn't act on them for two, three weeks. Then got the email from the husband, the husband reported something. Now this doesn't have to be severe as this, but it can be, if there's any form of risk to our client, whether that's a child, whether that's a vulnerable patient and you're aware of that risk, it's a good idea to seek advice from your supervisor and then escalate it very quickly. So in the case of this person, this client didn't escalate it for about a month.
是客户的丈夫通知她，说在你手下工作的人正在与我的妻子建立关系。现在，我的客户很快就意识到了这一点。她早就怀疑有些事情不对劲，但两三周都没有采取行动。然后收到了丈夫的电子邮件，丈夫报告了一些事情。这不一定非要像这样严重，但如果对我们的客户有任何形式的风险，无论是孩子，还是弱势患者，而你意识到了这种风险，寻求主管的建议并迅速升级是一个好主意。所以在这个人的案例中，这位客户大约一个月没有升级。
And during that time, there was a couple more sessions. Now this became a real problem for my client because she did not report that and she was in danger in the public. So if you're aware of something, have a chat with your supervisor. And if you're still not confident about that advice, go to your body. And if you're still feeling a little bit worried about it, you can even contact the HCPC and ask in this. You can ask if not anonymously, you can say hypothetically, this is what's happened. Should I report it? But as soon as you know something's right, it's not happening in relation to risk management,
在那段时间里，又进行了几次会谈。这对我客户来说成了一个真正的问题，因为她没有报告，而且她处于公众的危险之中。所以如果你意识到某事，和你的主管聊聊。如果你仍然对那个建议没有信心，就去找你的机构。如果你仍然感到有点担心，你甚至可以联系HCPC并询问。你可以问，不是匿名地，你可以说假设发生了这种情况。我应该报告吗？但一旦你知道某事在风险管理方面是不对的，
make sure you act as soon as possible. That's really another advice that I'd give. That's so interesting. So actually someone else's fitness to practice concern, if you hold on for that too long, could also then become your own fitness to practice concern because you're not protecting clients and the public? Yeah, I mean, that's an extreme example, but it's a good idea, keeping in mind the fact that
确保尽快采取行动。这真的是我给出的另一个建议。太有趣了。所以实际上，如果对他人的执业能力问题拖延太久，也可能变成你自己的执业能力问题，因为你没有保护客户和公众？是的，我的意思是，这是一个极端的例子，但记住这样一个事实是个好主意：
HCPC there is there to protect the public and that's its primary motivating force, really that's what it's there to do. So if in any way, shape or form you're hindering that, or you're aware of that, it makes sense that the HCPC will look into your actions as well, particularly if you're in a more senior position. So this was more of a, she was the supervisor for one of better expression. So she had some form of leadership role with this woman,
HCPC的存在是为了保护公众，这是其主要的驱动力，这确实是它存在的目的。所以，如果你以任何方式、形式或形态阻碍了这一点，或者你意识到了这一点，HCPC也会调查你的行为，特别是如果你处于更高级的职位时。所以这更多的是，用更好的表达方式来说，她是主管。所以她对这个女人有某种领导角色，
but you just be aware of any risks. So the fact that many clients can be highly vulnerable due to the nature of the industry, means that any endangerment of these people is heightened. So any sort of risk to someone who's highly vulnerable will be viewed differently by the HCPC to someone who isn't, and that makes sense. So if you're working in a different industry
但你只需要意识到任何风险。事实上，由于行业的性质，许多客户可能非常脆弱，这意味着对这些人的任何危害都会加剧。因此，HCPC对高度脆弱的人所面临的任何风险的看法，与对非脆弱的人的看法是不同的，这是有道理的。所以如果你在不同的行业工作
outside of psychology, but it's regulated by the HCPC, and the person you're working with is of sound mind and who, and actually can understand the process. That's gonna be viewed differently to if you're working with someone who's suffering from severe trauma, has been sexually abused, may have an addiction issue, you need to be more careful what you're doing with them. But that's common sense, I think.
在心理学之外，但受HCPC监管，而你一起工作的人头脑清醒，并且实际上能够理解这个过程。这与你与遭受严重创伤、遭受过性虐待、可能有成瘾问题的人一起工作时的看法是不同的，你需要对他们更小心。但我认为这是常识。
you need to be more careful what you're doing with them. But that's common sense, I think. Thank you. Yeah, like, it's just really helpful to think about this. And I think often in psychology, maybe you think, oh, I'll have to worry about that when I get there. But I think it's just wise to be informed and to know what the processes would be
你需要对他们更小心。但我认为这是常识。谢谢。是的，思考这个问题真的很有帮助。我认为在心理学中，人们可能经常会想，哦，等我到了那个阶段再担心吧。但我认为了解情况并知道流程会是什么样的是明智的
and to know that this is not some magical thinking thing, that by learning about this, we're not welcoming in those kind of complaints. Yeah, really interesting stuff. Before the HCPC, I think it was the British Psychological Society that kind of did their own regulation. And I remember at the back of the Psychologist magazine,
并且知道这不是什么魔法思维，通过学习这些，我们并不是在欢迎那种投诉。是的，非常有趣的内容。在HCPC之前，我认为是英国心理学会（British Psychological Society）在进行自己的监管。我记得在《心理学家》杂志的背面，
there would be kind of results of people's fitness to practice, if they're kind of what they've done. And it did back in the day when I was an aspiring psychologist, make for quite interesting reading. Do these become public cases once they've kind of been upheld, I guess, Nicholas? Yeah, interesting question. Yes. So essentially, it's in the public domain once if an adverse decision has been reached at the final hearing, which is, I guess,
会有人们的执业能力结果，如果他们做了什么的话。在我还是一个有抱负的心理学家时，这确实读起来很有趣。尼古拉斯，这些案件一旦被维持原判，会成为公开案件吗？是的，有趣的问题。是的。本质上，如果最终听证会达成了不利的决定，它就在公共领域了，我想
another purpose of the HCPC. So if you're a member of the public and you want to make sure that your psychologist that you're about to entrust your life, your health, or your child's health with, doesn't have any complaints raised against them that have reached, that have been upheld at final hearing. So yes, there is a website as part of the HCPC
这是HCPC的另一个目的。所以如果你是公众的一员，并且你想确保你即将托付生命、健康或孩子健康的心理学家，没有任何针对他们的投诉达到、在最终听证会上被维持原判。所以是的，HCPC网站上有一个网站
where you can click on and you can see all the cases. So you're, so people will check that up. Members of the public will check that up. They'll go and have a look at the role to see whether someone has been struck off. Sometimes some people keep on practicing that happens across all professions. A ruling happens against them
你可以点击查看所有案件。所以，人们会去查。公众成员会去查。他们会去看看名单，看看某人是否被除名。有时有些人继续执业，这种情况在所有行业都会发生。针对他们的裁决发生了
and then they just pretend it never happened. And the HCPC then have to act accordingly, which is complicated. But the process is actually, in most cases, a public process. So for example, if it goes to a final hearing or even a interim order application, members of the public can come and sit in on that
然后他们就假装从未发生过。HCPC随后必须采取相应的行动，这很复杂。但这个过程实际上在大多数情况下是一个公开的过程。例如，如果它进入最终听证会，甚至是临时命令申请，公众成员可以进来旁听
unless it's decided that it's a close hearing due to protection of privacy, which in psychological cases can happen quite often due to the nature of the work. But you should be aware that in theory, it is a public hearing. So if you're having an interim order hearing, a member of the press can come in the extreme cases. But if the case is closed before by the investigating team, or if it's closed by the investigating committee panel, then that will not be recorded in the public.
除非决定因保护隐私而进行闭门听证，这在心理学案件中由于工作的性质经常发生。但你应该意识到，理论上，这是一个公开听证会。所以如果你正在进行临时命令听证会，新闻界成员可以进来，在极端情况下。但如果案件在之前被调查小组关闭，或者被调查委员会小组关闭，那么它将不会被记录在公众中。
The HCPC will keep record of that for a certain amount of time. I think it's five years, a five year rule. So they will be aware that there has been a complaint raised against this person that's reached ICP, but there'll be no documented evidence. So therefore, if a member of the public wants to know, hey, I'm just hiring Dr Trent, is there any, has there been any complaints raised against her? Unless it's been
HCPC会将记录保留一段时间。我想是五年，五年规则。所以他们会意识到针对此人有投诉达到ICP，但不会有书面证据。因此，如果公众成员想知道，嘿，我正在雇佣特伦特博士，是否有任何针对她的投诉？除非它在
upheld at final hearing, there'll be no record of that. So it's worth knowing that it's only in the extreme cases that reach final hearing that your reputation will be affected. Yeah, that is useful to know. And for anyone that's watching this, who is looking for therapy or treatment from a regulated, protected title person, such as a clinical psychologist, the way you can check the register is to go to the HCPC website, or if you Google HCPC, check the register, then you put in the person's surname. I think you can put in which area they're practising in, but even if you Google HCPC, check the register, then you put in the person's surname. I think you can put in which area they're practising in, but even if you don't know that, you can just put in their surname and it will search for anybody who is registered in that name
最终听证会上被维持原判，否则不会有记录。所以值得知道的是，只有达到最终听证会的极端案件才会影响你的声誉。是的，这很有用。对于任何正在观看此视频、正在寻找受监管、受保护头衔的人（如临床心理学家）提供的治疗的人，你可以通过访问HCPC网站来检查注册，或者如果你在谷歌上搜索“HCPC，检查注册”，然后输入此人的姓氏。我想你可以输入他们执业的领域，但即使你不知道，你也可以只输入他们的姓氏，它会搜索所有以该名字注册的人
and give you kind of the area that they work in. And it will give you their registration number. And that is the evidence that that person is appropriately registered with the professional body. Nicholas, it's been really, really helpful. Could you give us an overview about, I guess, where you come in? So what you do and if someone was going to try to reach out to you, what services could you offer? Yeah, thanks. Thanks very much for that. So as I said, my background is I was a I am a lawyer based with a great deal of experience across many different fields, criminal, regulatory, human rights law, but for the last five to about eight years, I've been working
并给出他们工作的领域。它会给出他们的注册号。这就是该人已在专业机构适当注册的证据。尼古拉斯，这真的非常有帮助。你能给我们一个概述吗，关于，我想，你介入的地方？所以你做什么，如果有人想联系你，你能提供什么服务？是的，谢谢。非常感谢。正如我所说，我的背景是，我是一名律师，在许多不同领域拥有丰富的经验，刑事、监管、人权法，但在过去五到八年里，我一直致力于
exclusively in regulation law, primarily with HCPC registrants. Now what I try and do is assist people in some of the psychological aspect of it. So I work a fair bit with the ACP UK and we run webinars together. And that is not strictly legal. A lot of that is really helping people navigate the process because it's a stormy waters out there. It really can be quite unsettling.
专门从事监管法，主要是针对HCPC注册者。现在我尝试做的是在心理学方面协助人们。所以我与ACP UK合作得相当多，我们一起举办网络研讨会。这并不严格是法律上的。很多实际上是在帮助人们导航这个过程，因为外面的水很深。它确实可能相当令人不安。
So what I do is I run webinars on how to navigate the process and the various steps you can take. I also run webinars on professional boundaries issues and some of the legal, some actual more legal issues that people face. And I mainly really assist psychologists at the moment, but also paramedics and the health-based industries in their HCPC process.
所以我做的是举办关于如何导航这个过程以及你可以采取的各种步骤的网络研讨会。我还举办关于专业边界问题以及人们面临的一些法律、一些实际更法律问题的网络研讨会。我目前主要协助心理学家，但也协助护理人员和健康行业人员处理他们的HCPC流程。
So if you have a complaint raised against you, I'm happy to assist in the process of responding to the allegation. And that can just be a general chat. And then if it does actually reach an ICP level, what one needs to do is they need to respond to each individual allegation. And I help people write that.
所以如果你有针对你的投诉，我很乐意协助回应指控的过程。这可以只是一个一般的聊天。然后如果它确实达到了ICP水平，人们需要做的是他们需要回应每一项单独的指控。我帮助人们写这些。
And then if it goes forward to a hearing, I can represent them at a final hearing. But the great majority of the work that I do and people similar to me is assisting people in the initial stages, because it doesn't normally go to final hearing. People need to understand the final hearing is not really the likely outcome unless there's a major, unless it's a very serious matter. But having someone walk with you through the process and having someone assist you in writing those initial responses to the HCPC,
然后如果它进入听证会，我可以在最终听证会上代表他们。但我所做的大部分工作以及像我这样的人所做的工作是在初始阶段协助人们，因为它通常不会进入最终听证会。人们需要理解最终听证会并不是真正可能的结果，除非有重大事项，除非是非常严重的事情。但有人陪你走过这个过程，有人协助你写那些对HCPC的初步回应，
that's really useful and I have a great deal of experience in that. Would that be something that's funded by the individual themselves or would their indemnity insurer, for example, pay your bills? That depends. Generally, from my experience and the great majority of clients I have, they're self-funded because they have an indemnity insurer and generally what these organizations do is they will send you to a particular lawyer. And a lot of my clients, in fact, the great majority of my clients have not been happy with the service they've received from that lawyer. It's not necessarily that the legal aspect that they're doing is, they're assisting with is not good.
这真的很有用，我在这方面有丰富的经验。这会是由个人自己资助，还是他们的赔偿保险公司，例如，支付你的账单？这取决于。通常，根据我的经验和我拥有的大多数客户，他们是自费的，因为他们有赔偿保险公司，通常这些组织所做的是他们会把你送到特定的律师那里。事实上，我的许多客户，绝大多数客户对他们从那位律师那里得到的服务并不满意。这不一定是因为他们协助的法律方面不好。
It was obviously these are highly competent lawyers. It's understanding psychologically how they're dealing with the process. So my sort of area of expertise is working with people in a psychological sense as well, and not just a strictly legal sense. And I think my experience with the HCPC and understanding how traumatic this whole process can be, yeah, it means that I can offer something slightly different.
显然这些是能力很强的律师。这是在心理上理解他们如何处理这个过程。所以我那种专业领域也是在心理意义上与人合作，而不仅仅是严格的法律意义。我认为我对HCPC的经验以及理解整个过程可能有多么创伤，是的，意味着我可以提供一些稍微不同的东西。
On certain circumstances, you can designate and you can choose who you want to assist you in your matter. And that depends on your actual indemnity insurer. So that's something you can make contact with them themselves. But generally self-funded. That's how it works. Okay. And is it okay if I ask for a ballpark figure about what someone might be expecting to pay per hour or kind of for a piece of work? Because I know when we're trying to kind of think about whether people can afford things, it can be kind of quite helpful. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, that's, I think that's really where I've, I've changed people's
在某些情况下，你可以指定并选择你想要谁来协助你处理你的事情。这取决于你实际的赔偿保险公司。所以这是你可以与他们联系的事情。但通常是自费的。这就是它的工作方式。好的。如果我问一个关于某人可能期望每小时支付多少钱或某种工作的大致数字，可以吗？因为我知道当我们试图考虑人们是否负担得起事情时，这可能非常有帮助。是的，绝对可以。我的意思是，我认为这确实是我改变人们
perceptions on, on how much these sort of things should cost. Because in a, in a strictly monetary sense, getting legal advice from the start of a process to the end of the process can be anywhere between five and 10,000 pounds. But what I do is I break it down to what we're going to do now is we're going to just focus on preparing the response to allegations. We have a few chats. So generally for the initial process and the initial stage, if it does go to an ICP, we're looking around 1500 pounds. So it's, I charge about 110, 120 pounds an hour, which is half the rate of other lawyers. And the reason I do that is the nature of the work
对这些事情应该花费多少的看法的地方。因为在严格的货币意义上，从过程开始到过程结束获得法律建议可能在5000到10000英镑之间。但我所做的是将其分解为我们现在要做的是我们将只专注于准备对指控的回应。我们有几次聊天。所以通常对于初始过程和初始阶段，如果它确实进入ICP，我们大约在1500英镑左右。所以我收费大约每小时110、120英镑，这是其他律师费率的一半。我这样做的原因是工作的性质
is not that, unless you're going to an actual hearing, and that's where it becomes, the hours start to really accumulate. This is about having friendly dialogue, friendly chats and giving psychological advice as well as legal advice. I think that it sounds a little bit cliched, but walking people through the process. So I think at £110 an hour is generally £110 to £120 depending on the nature of the case.
不是那样的，除非你要去实际的听证会，那是小时数开始真正积累的地方。这是关于进行友好的对话、友好的聊天，并提供心理建议以及法律建议。我认为这听起来有点陈词滥调，但引导人们走过这个过程。所以我认为每小时110英镑通常是110到120英镑，具体取决于案件的性质。
Thank you. That's really helpful to know because I think often when we're working closely with lawyers and they bill in four minute increments, it can feel like I have no idea how much this is going to all cost. Yeah, I don't do that at all. Okay, that's good to know. Thank you so much for your time. What's the best way for people to reach out to you if they would like to learn more about working with you? Yeah, I think the best way to reach out is via email. That's generally having a personal communication I've found is the best way of going. So my email is nicknick.stockling.com.
谢谢。这真的很有帮助，因为我认为通常当我们与律师密切合作并且他们以四分钟为增量计费时，可能会感觉我不知道这一切将花费多少。是的，我根本不那样做。好的，很高兴知道。非常感谢你的时间。如果人们想了解更多关于与你合作的信息，联系你的最好方式是什么？是的，我认为联系的最好方式是通过电子邮件。我发现进行个人交流通常是最好的方式。所以我的电子邮件是nicknick.stockling.com。
So nick.stockling.consulting.com. Amazing. I will make sure that's on screen for anyone watching on YouTube and it will be in the show notes and in the description for YouTube and wherever you get your podcasts as well. Thank you so much for your time and for illuminating this process for us because of course it can feel very triggering but hopefully Forearmed is forewarned and people do come out the other side don't they? They do manage to to assimilate this into their lives, put it behind them and go forward without thinking about it every day. Absolutely, it is something that is is manageable with the appropriate steps and the appropriate understanding of the process. It's something you can absolutely work through and something that having a broader understanding of
所以nick.stockling.consulting.com。太棒了。我会确保在YouTube上观看的任何人都能在屏幕上看到它，它也会在节目说明中，以及YouTube的描述中，以及你获取播客的任何地方。非常感谢你的时间，并为我们阐明了这个过程，因为当然它可能会让人感到非常触发，但希望有备无患，人们确实会从另一边走出来，不是吗？他们确实设法将此融入他们的生活中，将其抛在脑后，并继续前进，而不必每天都在想它。绝对，这是一个可以通过适当步骤和对过程的适当理解来管理的事情。这是你可以绝对克服的事情，也是拥有更广泛理解的事情
is very worthwhile in terms of preparing yourself for the worst and every eventuality. Thank you so much for your time and yes, do stay in touch. Thanks very much. Much appreciated. Thank you, Daniglus, for his time. It was a really illuminating conversation. I hope that's helped put your mind at ease or maybe given you some useful nuggets to store away for future as well. If you have found this helpful, please do drop a like, a comment, please do consider sharing it with your colleagues. If you are watching on YouTube,
在为最坏的情况和每一种可能性做准备方面是非常值得的。非常感谢你的时间，是的，保持联系。非常感谢。非常感激。谢谢丹尼格勒斯的时间。这是一次真正具有启发性的谈话。我希望这有助于让你安心，或者可能给你一些有用的信息，以便将来存储起来。如果你觉得这有帮助，请点赞、评论，请考虑与你的同事分享。如果你正在YouTube上观看，
if you're listening on MP3, please do rate and review on Apple podcasts. Please do rate on Spotify and please, wherever you are watching or listening, please do subscribe or follow the show. If you are interested in how to find a qualified and regulated psychologist or therapist, then please do check out the book which I wrote with my colleague Dr Tara Quintarillo, which you can find called Talking Heads, your guide to finding a qualified therapist in the UK. There is a link to that in the bio. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you've got ideas for future episodes I would love
如果你正在收听MP3，请在Apple播客上评分和评论。请在Spotify上评分，无论你在哪里观看或收听，请订阅或关注该节目。如果你对如何找到合格且受监管的心理学家或治疗师感兴趣，那么请查看我与我的同事塔拉·昆塔里洛博士合著的书，你可以找到名为《Talking Heads，你在英国寻找合格治疗师的指南》。简介中有一个链接。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你对未来的剧集有想法，我很乐意
to hear them. Please do drop me a comment, drop me a like. Please do come and follow me on socials where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Mary Antrim There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听到它们。请给我留言，给我点赞。请来社交媒体上关注我，我在那里到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上成为合格的道路，这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，与玛丽·安特里姆博士一起。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。